[ Music ]
JEAN-FRANCOIS BILODEAU: Think about
how quickly a minor misconfiguration
in the cloud can turn into
a major security incident,
a storage account
exposed to the internet,
an unpatched server spun
up for a quick test,
or an API that quietly starts
leaking sensitive data.
In a hybrid multi-cloud world,
those gaps can be hard to spot
until an attacker
finds them first.
Let me introduce you to a
course where you will learn how
to tackle these
real-world scenarios
by improving your security
posture, protecting workload,
and responding to threats with
Microsoft Defender for Cloud.
Hello and welcome.
We are glad you've joined us.
I am Jean-Francois Bilodeau, a
Microsoft Technical Trainer.
In this session, we will
cover Learning Path 5,
Mitigate Threats Using
Microsoft Defender for Cloud.
Together, we will look at what
Microsoft Defender for Cloud is;
how to enable it; how to connect
Azure and non-Azure assets
to it; how to use posture
management features
like Secure Score
and recommendations;
which workloads can be
protected; and, finally,
how to respond to and automate
remediation for security alerts.
By the end, you will know how
to turn Defender for Cloud
into a practical day-to-day tool
for reducing risk and speeding
up investigation and response.
So let's get started
with this session.
Here, we set the stage
for the broader goal,
defending against cyberthreats
using Microsoft Security
Operations platform.
We will focus our attention
on Learning Path 5
where the objective is
to mitigate threats using
Defender for Cloud.
This Learning Path is designed
to help you move from visibility
to action so you can
harden your cloud posture
and respond effectively when
something suspicious happens.
Let's take a look at
what we will cover
across the learning Path.
We will start by planning cloud
workload protection using
Microsoft Defender for Cloud.
Then we'll connect Azure
assets and we'll bring
in non-Azure assets as well
so you can see how Defender
for Cloud supports hybrid and
multi-cloud environments.
Next, we'll manage Cloud
Security Posture Management
using a tool like the Secure
Score, recommendation
and compliance insights.
From there, we'll walk through
workload protection available
in Defender for Cloud, and
we'll wrap up by remediating
and responding to security
alerts using Defender for Cloud.
Now, let's begin with planning
for cloud workload protection.
Before you enable anything,
it helps to understand
what Defender
for Cloud actually does,
what kind of protection
it can provide,
and how those protections align
with the workload you run.
In this module, the goals
are straightforward.
First, you will be able
to describe Microsoft Defender
for Cloud's features.
Second, you will be able
to explain the workload
protection available
in Defender for Cloud.
And, third, you will learn how
to enable Microsoft Defender
for Cloud so those capabilities
can actually be applied
to your environment.
Microsoft Defender for Cloud
brings together several
important security capabilities.
From a development
security operation,
or a DevSecOps perspective, it
unifies security management
at the code level
across multi-cloud
and multiple pipeline
environments, helping security
and development teams
work from the same set
of signals and priorities.
From a Cloud Security
Posture Management, or CSPM,
perspective, it surfaces actions
you can take to prevent breaches
by improving configuration
and reducing exposure.
And, from a Cloud Workload
Protection Platform, or CWPP,
perspective, it provides
specific protection
for common workload types like
servers, containers, storage,
database, and more, so
you can detect threats
and investigate suspicious
activity where it matters most.
As you evaluate Defender
for Cloud, you'll notice
that capabilities are organized
into plans, typically aligning
to posture management and
workload protection needs.
Here, we are looking
at the plans option
and the newer CSPM Plan Matrix,
which helps you understand what
features are included based
on the plan you choose.
This is important because
enabling the right plan is what
determines which
controls, insights,
and detection becomes
available to your subscription
and connected environments.
To use all of Defender for
Cloud features including threat
protection, you need to enable
enhanced security features
on the subscription
that contains the workload
you want to protect.
In practice, that means
going into the Defender
for Cloud experience in the
Azure Portal and turning
on the right plan for the
right scope so onboarding
and detection can start applying
on the resource in
that subscription.
With Defender for Cloud enabled,
the next step is making sure
the right assets are actually
connected because
your security posture
and threat signals
are only as complete
as the inventory
you are monitoring.
Let's take a look at how to
connect both Azure resources
and assets that live
outside of Azure.
In this module, you will learn
how to explore Azure assets,
configure settings, and
monitoring onboarding
in Defender for Cloud, and
integrate Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint with
Defender for Cloud.
Then, we'll cover
how to connect Azure
and non-Azure machines
and, finally,
how to connect AWS
accounts and GCP projects
so you can extend your
security management
across multi-cloud environments.
Here, we use the asset inventory
to get a practical view
of what Defender for
Cloud is tracking.
You can start from
an inventory summary
that shows total resources,
how many are unhealthy,
how many are unmonitored,
and even whether they are an
unregistered subscription.
From there, you can
drill into the status
of each resource looking
at whether agent monitoring
is enabled, whether Defender
for Cloud protections
are applied,
and which recommendations are
associated with that asset.
As the onscreen flow animates
through these areas,
the key takeaway is that
inventory isn't just a list,
it's a way to prioritize
coverage gaps and quickly focus
on the resource that
needs attention.
Next, let's take a
look at configuration.
Microsoft Defender for Cloud
can automatically onboard Azure
resources and even
non-Azure resources
by installing the
right extension.
When you enable an extension,
Defender for Cloud installs it
on the new and existing resource
by assigning a security policy.
That means you are not manually
touching every virtual machine
or every service one by one.
Instead, you set the
onboarding behavior centrally
in the environment setting
and monitoring configuration,
and Defender for Cloud
applies it consistently
across the selected scope.
Now, let's shift from Azure-only
to hybrid and multi-cloud.
If you run servers
on-premise, in other cloud,
or in a mixed environment,
you still want a single place
to understand risk and
respond to threat.
And that's exactly what
connecting to non-Azure assets
to Defender for Cloud enables.
In this module, we will
focus on three outcomes:
connecting a non-Azure machine
to Microsoft Defender for Cloud,
connecting an AWS account,
and connecting GCP projects.
The idea here is to extend
the same posture management
and threat protection
capabilities beyond Azure
so you can manage security
across your entire estate.
To protect non-Azure resources,
Azure Arc plays a central role.
Azure Arc simplifies
governance and management
by delivering a
consistent multi-cloud
and on-premise
management platform.
In other words, you can project
servers and Kubernetes clusters
that runs outside Azure
into Azure management
and then apply
policies, monitoring,
and security control,
including Defender for Cloud,
more consistently across
all your environments.
When connecting individual
non-Azure machines,
there's a few key
paths to understand.
With Azure Arc enabled,
you install the
Azure-connected machine agent
on a non-Azure host to bring
them under Azure Arc management.
From there, you use a Sata
Collection Rule, or DCR,
to onboard monitoring
by installing the Azure
Monitoring Agent,
often called AMA.
You can add an Azure-connected
Windows machine
to a DCR resource
to install AMA.
And you can also add our
connected Linux machine
as a DCR resource
to install AMA.
Another important integration is
Microsoft Defender for Endpoint.
You can onboard at the tenant
level using direct onboarding
enabled in the Defender for
Cloud management settings,
and then use the standard
Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint onboarding method.
You can also use Azure
Portal-based onboarding
approach, such as
workspace-level direct
onboarding, depending on
how you manage monitoring
and security operations today.
Let's take a look
at connecting AWS.
When you onboard your AWS
account in Microsoft Defender
for Cloud, you integrate
AWS Security Hub.
The result is that Defender for
Cloud can now provide visibility
and protection signals
across both environments
so you can access posture
and surface findings
into a more unified
way instead of jumping
between separate
portals and dashboards.
And, for Google Cloud,
the approach is similar.
Onboarding your GCP account
into Microsoft Defender
for Cloud integrates GCP
security command center,
allowing Defender for Cloud
to operate visibility
and protection across
both cloud environments.
Once your assets are connected,
the next priority
is understanding
and improving your
overall security posture.
Let's explore the Cloud Security
Posture Management capabilities
in Microsoft Defender for Cloud,
including scoring, benchmark,
recommendation,
and risk analysis
across your environment.
In this module, we're
aiming for three outcomes.
First, you will be able
to describe the Defender
for Cloud Secure Score.
Second, you will
understand how Defender
for Cloud implements the
Microsoft Cloud Security
Benchmark, or MCSB.
And, third, you will be able
to explain the posture
management protection
that Defender for Cloud applies
to help you reduce risk
across your resources.
Secure Score gives
you a measurable way
to understand your
current security posture
and track improvement over time.
Here, we are looking at the
Security Score experience
in Defender for Cloud
where posture improvement
actions are translated
into points.
The practical value
is prioritization.
You can identify high-impact
recommendations,
understand what's driving the
score up or down, and then use
that score as a simple
consistent indicator
of posture improvement
across your connected
subscription and environment.
It's also helpful to compare
how Secure Score is used
across different Microsoft
and cloud services.
For a SaaS like Microsoft 365,
the scoring experience is
Microsoft's Secure Score focus
on areas like identities,
devices, and apps.
And it's managed through the
Microsoft 365 Security Center.
For PaaS and IS scenarios,
Defender for Cloud
provides a Secure Score
through the Defender
for Cloud dashboard.
And, when you connect
other cloud providers,
you will see the scoring maps
to those ecosystems as well.
For AWS, posture
findings are provided
through AWS Security
Hub and, for GCP,
through the GCP Security
Command Center, while Defender
for Cloud brings those
signals together
so you can manage
them centrally.
This comparison is also
a useful optional moment
to connect what you
may have learned
about Microsoft Secure
Score earlier in the course
with Defender for Cloud
Secure Score here.
Recommendations are
where posture management
becomes actionable.
Here, we are looking at the
Recommendation View in Defender
for Cloud which consolidates
the specific steps you can take
to reduce risks, such as
hardening configuration,
addressing missing controls, or
improving monitoring coverage.
As you work with these
recommendations,
you typically prioritize
based on severity and impact,
assign ownership to
the right teams,
and track remediation
progress as part
of your ongoing
security operations.
Defender for Cloud also helps
you align to a recognized set
of security control through
the Microsoft Cloud Security
Benchmark, or MCSB.
This benchmark is automatically
assigned to your subscription
and account when you
onboard Defender for Cloud.
It builds on the cloud
security principle defined
by the Azure Security
Benchmark and extends them
with detailed technical
implementation guidance not only
for Azure, but also for other
cloud providers like AWS
and GCP, and even for
other Microsoft Cloud.
The result is a consistent
control framework you can use
to drive posture improvement
and compliance discussion
across the environment.
Building on that, you can
measure compliance directly
in Defender for Cloud.
The Microsoft Cloud Security
Benchmark is the default policy
initiative for
Defender for Cloud,
and it forms the foundation
of the security
recommendations you see.
This means compliance reporting
and posture recommendations
are connected.
As you remediate findings
and implement control,
you are not only improving
your Secure Score,
you are also strengthening
alignment to the benchmarks
and the compliance
requirement mapped to them.
Beyond scores and checklists,
Defender for Cloud can
help you understand risk
as an attacker would across
identities, network exposure,
permissions, and
resource relationships.
Here, we use Attack
Path Analysis
and Cloud Security
Explorer to scan
and query the Cloud
Security Graph.
The Cloud Security Graph is
a graph-based context engine
inside Defender for
Cloud that collects data
from your multi-cloud
environment and other sources
like the cloud assets
inventory, connections,
and potential lateral movement
path between your resources,
internet exposure, permissions,
network connection,
vulnerabilities, and more.
That data is used to build
a graph representing your
environment which then
supports richer risk analysis
than isolated alert
or individual
configuration findings.
Attack Path Analysis is designed
to expose the chain of condition
that would enable a
successful breach.
Instead of only telling you that
something is misconfigured,
it shows you how multiple
weaknesses can connect turning a
path from an entry point
to a high-value target.
Event suggests recommendations
to remediate the issue
that would break that path in
helping you prioritize fixes
that reduces real-world
attack viabilities.
Cloud Security Explorer gives
you a query builder experience
so you can run graph-based
queries across your environment.
This is especially useful when
you want to answer questions
like "show me internet exposed
resources with high privileges"
or "find path to sensitive
data" without having
to manually correlate dozens
of separate findings.
The query experience leverages
the Cloud Security Graph
to surface results with context.
To visualize trend and
operational insight,
you can use workbooks.
These give you the readymade
dashboards for scenarios
like Secure Score over
time, system updates,
vulnerability
assessment finding,
compliance over time,
and active alerts.
Workbooks help translate large
volumes of security data
in a format that's easier
to track, report on,
and review with stakeholders.
Now that we've covered
posture management,
let's move into workload
protection where Defender
for Cloud shifts from how
secure are we configured
to how are we detecting
and responding to threats
against the workload we run.
In this module, you will learn
how workloads are protected
by Microsoft Defender
for Cloud, the benefits
of those protections, and how
the protections function.
The goal is to help you
understand not only what's
covered, like servers,
containers, and storage,
but also how Defender for
Cloud connects signals,
generates alerts, and supports
investigation and remediation.
For server protection, Defender
for Cloud offers a Microsoft
Defender for Server plan.
Plan 1 deploys Microsoft
Defender for Endpoint
to your servers and provides
an important benefit.
Licensing for Microsoft Defender
for Endpoint is charged per
hour instead of per seat,
which can lower cost when you
are protecting a virtual machine
only while they are running.
Defender for Endpoint can
also deploy automatically
to cloud workload, ensuring
new workloads are protected
as they spin up.
And the alerts and vulnerability
data coming from Defender
for Endpoints are then shown
directly in Microsoft Defender
for Cloud so you can view from
a more unified security view.
Plan 2, which was formerly known
simply as Defender for Servers,
includes all the benefit
of Plan 1 and adds support
for the other Microsoft
Defender for Servers feature,
so it's the option you choose
when you need the most
comprehensive server
protection capabilities.
Here, we are looking at where
server protection is configured
through Defender for Cloud
settings and Defender plans.
This is where we assess
our servers' inventory
and see what's covered and
where we configure provisioning
so the right agents and
extension are deployed.
One important note, if you
turn off autoprovisioning
of the agent, you will need
to manually install the
Azure Monitoring Agent
on your virtual machine.
This setting can have a
big impact on coverage
so it's worth validating
during rollout.
For an application hosted
on Azure App Services,
Microsoft Defender for App
Service uses the scale
of the cloud to identify attacks
targeting those applications.
Attackers often probe
web applications looking
for weaknesses they can exploit.
Before requests are routed
to a specific environment,
traffic to application
running in Azure passes
through multiple gateways
where requests are
inspected and logged.
Defender uses that data to
identify exploits and attackers,
and to learn new patterns
that can be used
and applied later to
improve detection.
When something
suspicious is detected,
Defender for App Service
generates an alert
that you can
investigate and remedy.
Defender for Cloud also provides
cloud workload protection
for database.
The idea here is to detect
suspicious behavior
and attack targeting
database services
so you can identify threats,
such as abnormal access pattern
or potential
exploitation attempts.
For Azure SQL Database
specifically,
Defender for Cloud provides
a set of alerts designed
to surface these
database-related threats
and guide investigation.
Looking more broadly at database
coverage, Microsoft Defender
for Database includes threat
protection for Azure Cosmos DB.
It also provides
threat protection
for open-source
relational databases,
including Azure Database for
PostgreS, Azure Database
for MySQL and Azure
Database for MariahDB.
For each database type, there
is additional documentation
available to help you
understand the detection,
onboarding requirement, and
the investigation workflow.
And, for open-source
relational databases,
Defender for Cloud also provides
a defined set of alerts
that describe what kind
of suspicious activities
can be detected.
Storage is another
high-value target.
And Microsoft Defender
for Storage provides detection
focused on suspicious access
or activities involving
storage accounts.
When Defender detects
potentially malicious behavior,
such as unusual access
pattern, it generates an alert
that helps you investigate
what happened and decides
on remediation steps to
reduce ongoing risks.
For containerized environments,
Microsoft Defender
for Container protects
your clusters
across multiple platforms.
That includes Azure
Kubernetes Services, or AKS,
Amazon Elastic Kubernetes
Services, or EKS,
when it's running in a
connected AWS account,
and unmanaged
Kubernetes distribution
when they are connected using
Azure Arc-enabled Kubernetes.
This coverage is important
because Kubernetes clusters
can host many workloads
and identities, and the
ability to detect threats
and misconfiguration
consistently
across environment helps
reduce blind spots.
Microsoft Defender for
Key Vault detects unusual
and potentially harmful
attempts to access
or exploit Key Vault accounts.
This layer of
protection is designed
to help you address
threats without needing
to be a security expert and
without having to deploy
and manage a third-party
security monitoring system.
When anomalous activities occur,
Defender for Cloud
shows an alert
that can optionally
send them by email
to the relevant people
in your organization.
These alerts include detail of
the suspicious activities along
with recommendation
on how to investigate
and remediate the threats.
Microsoft Defender for Resource
Manager focuses on threats
and suspicious activity at
the Azure management layer.
It helps protect against
suspicious resource management
operations like actions on
malicious IP addresses,
attempts to disable
anti-malware,
or suspicious script running
in virtual machine extensions.
It can also detect the
use of exploitation kits,
such as a microburst or a
power surge, and, importantly,
it helps address scenarios
including lateral movement
from the Azure management layer
into the Azure
resource data plane
where attackers may
attempt to pivot
from control plane access
to workload access.
Defender for API helps
you gain visibility
in your business-critical
APIs so you can investigate
and improve security posture,
prioritize vulnerability fixes,
and detect against the
top OWASP API threats.
It provides a unified inventory
of all APIs published
within Azure API Management.
It can monitor API traffic
against top OWASP API threats
using machine learning-based
detection and threat
intelligence-based detection.
It also delivers
security insights,
such as identifying
unauthenticated APIs, inactive
or dormant APIs, and
externally exposed APIs.
And it can classify APIs
that receive or respond
with sensitive data, helping
you focus protection
where the business impact
is at the highest.
Workload protection also extends
into the entire
development pipeline.
Defender for DevOps provides
a unified visibility
into the DevOps Security posture
through a central console
so a security administrator
can see DevOps inventory
and posture in one place.
It helps strengthen cloud
resources configuration
throughout the development
lifecycle by enabling security
for infrastructure as Code
templates and container images,
reducing the chance
that misconfiguration
makes it to production.
It also helps prioritize
remediation of critical issues
in Code using Pull
Request annotations
and assigning
developer ownership
so fixes can be
tracked and completed.
And it's worth noting that
DevOps Security is available
in commercial cloud across
multiple regions including part
of Asia, Australia, Canada,
United States, UK, and Europe.
Here, we can see what it
looks like in practice.
The DevOps Security page
acts as a central console
where you can view all
onboarding environments along
with key metrics.
This gives you an
at-a-glance understanding
of where coverage exists, which
posture issues are concentrated,
and which environments may
need immediate attention
from security and
development team.
At this point, we have talked
about postures and protections.
Now we will focus on what
happens when Defender
for Cloud actually detects
something suspicious.
Let's walk through how alerts
work, how you respond,
and how you can automate part
of your remediation workflow.
In this module, you will
learn how to describe alerts
in Microsoft Defender for Cloud,
how to respond to those alerts,
and how to automate response
in Defender for Cloud
so that common remediation
action can run consistently
and quickly.
Here, we focus on what security
alerts really represent
in Microsoft Defender for Cloud.
Security alerts and
incidents are generated
when Defender detects behavior
that may indicate a threat.
These detections are based
on continuous monitoring
and ongoing security assessment
across your environment.
Alerts are classified to help
you understand the nature
and severity of the issue,
and can represent anything
from suspicious activity to
confirmed malicious behavior.
Understanding alert types
and how they're generated
is the first step
in responding effectively
and consistently.
Once an alert is raised,
Microsoft Defender
for Cloud helps
guide your response.
Here, we see how alerts
provide actionable tasks
that helps you mitigate the
threat, prevent similar attacks
in the future, or trigger
an automated response.
You can also suppress
alerts when appropriate,
such as when you've confirmed
an alert is a false positive.
The goal is to move from
detection to action quickly
without losing
important context.
For recurring or
well-understood scenarios,
automation can significantly
reduce response time.
Here, we look at how you
can create a logic app
and define the condition
under which it should
automatically run.
By automating alert responses,
you ensure that remediation
steps are applied consistently
and immediately, even outside
normal working hours.
Not every alert requires
action every time.
Suppression rules are useful
when alerts are identified
as false positive or when
they trigger too frequently
to be useful.
Here, we explore how suppression
rules help reduce noise
so security teams can
stay focused on alerts
that truly matter without
losing visibility
in the overall security health.
Beyond individual alerts,
Defender for Cloud
also provides access
to threat intelligence reports.
These reports can
include information
such as activity groups,
campaigns, threat summaries.
When available, they may also
contain attacker identity
or association, attacker
objectives, and current
or historical attack campaigns.
You will also find details
against attackers' tactics,
tools, and procedures,
associated indicators
of compromise like URLs or
file hashes, victimology data,
and guidance on mitigation
and remediation.
This broader context helps
you understand not just what
happened, but why it matters.
Here, we bring everything
together with a focus
on responding to alerts from
specific Azure resources.
This includes responding
to Azure Defender
for Key Vault alerts, DNS
alerts, resource manager alerts.
This is also where we
manage our alerts,
review the alert details,
and configure automation.
At this point, we will
move into a demonstration
that ties together the concept
from this Learning Path.
Here, we will see how Microsoft
Defender for Cloud is used end
to end to mitigate
threats from detection
through investigation
and response.
In this demonstration,
let's enable Microsoft
Defender for Cloud.
We have got the Azure Portal
open so let's navigate
to Defender for Cloud.
We'll just search for
it in the Search bar.
There is Microsoft
Defender for Cloud.
What we need to do now
is enable Defender
for Cloud for our subscription.
So let's head down to
Environment Settings
under the Management section.
Here is our management group
including our subscription.
We'll just expand everything,
select a subscription
where we want to enable
Defender for Cloud.
Within the subscription, we
can enable individual plan,
like Defender CSPM, foundational
is always turned on.
But let's enable Defender Cloud
Security Posture Management.
Done. Let's do the
same with our server.
Let's activate Plan 2.
On. Done. And we could
activate additional plans
if we wanted to for Defender.
But, for now, let's just save.
And we are good.
We have activated
Defender for Cloud.
We could also click
the "Enable All Plans"
to turn on everything.
Let's go back to
Defender for Cloud
and let's now explore some
useful capability like the
"What's New" button,
keep yourself up to date
with Defender for Cloud.
It evolves very quickly.
Next, let's review our
regulatory compliance.
Actually, we don't have any
so let's activate those,
Manage Regulatory Compliances.
From here, once again,
we'll select where we want
to activate that compliance.
We'll select "Our Subscription."
And, under Security Policies,
here is a list of compliances
that are already built
for you by Microsoft.
They're included in
Defender for Cloud.
Let's select "ISO 27001-2013."
And let's just enable it.
Done. We are good.
Now that we've assigned a
standard, let's take a look
at the recommendations
brought on by this standard.
We're going to head back
to Defender for Cloud,
just close our
Environmental Settings,
Regulatory Compliance,
back to the overview.
There is our recommendation.
Now, we're not going
to see recommendations
yet because we don't really
have resources onboarded,
and also the policy is
being applied right now.
But this is where we would see
the recommendations by Microsoft
for our Cloud Security
Posture Management.
Let's take a moment to
recap what we've covered
in this Learning Path.
We started by looking at
Microsoft Defender for Cloud
as a DevSecOps solution that
unifies security management
across multi-cloud and
multiple-pipeline environments.
We explored how it delivered
Cloud Security Posture
Management and cloud
workload protection;
how it protects workloads like
servers, containers, storage,
and databases; and how
it extends protection
to hybrid environments including
non-Azure machines, AWS and GCP.
Finally, we looked
at how Defender
for Cloud helps you remediate
alerts with actionable guidance
and automated responses.
This concludes our session.
There are many ways to continue
your learning journey.
We encourage you to watch other
videos in this course or search
for your own favorite topics on
Microsoft Learn at aka.ms/learn.